hello everyone this is amir from audio
science review i have an actual review
for you today
of this sacd player um i hope to get
through it quickly because i don't think
that many of you are interested in these
transports but uh member candy sent this
to me it's an expensive one for our
marianne's it costs 7 500
is this unit sitting over here i know
you can't see it that well so look at
the picture and the review
it's a multi-format transport uh
that plays sacd and of course cd
um oddly for an sacd player stereo only
uh i know a lot of people use sacd
format to get multi-channel high
resolution audio
but this hysteria only so it's really
for die hard two channel listeners for
those of you don't know sacd's format
that came out i think 30 years ago
during 1990s late 1990s
and it was sony and phillips's attempt
to replace the cd with something better
with the high resolution and of course
at that time copy protection was a huge
deal so
um they've
put in various measures in there to
basically make it impossible to
rip these there are some hacks out there
using playstation what have you to
take the copy make a copy but
it's not easy to find those hacks
and um
so in a way they succeeded with that but
they uh failed the larger war which is
you know if you made the format so hard
to access uh nobody wanted it anymore in
the era of you know you could go online
and download an mp3 why would you want
to jump through all these hoops uh the
record labels at the time they thought
this was their uh
rescue card from piracy of mp3
and uh
not realizing that extra bit of fidelity
even if it was there uh wasn't going to
get anybody to adopt it um cd was a
major jump forward in fidelity and
the little bit of performance is left in
the on the table as far as the cd
just isn't going to get that many people
to adopt the format
it also was in a big format war with
another format called dvd audio
from dvd forum and so they killed each
other that way too dvd audio died
completely but sacd hasn't actually as
you can see this player came out in 2017
and the digital version of this uh the
dsd download that i showed in the last
video
has got even more legs now than sacd
itself so they're very high-end
independent small vendors are are
producing the uh content um
the uh
the main class of people that like sacd
these days are classical music and
there's decent library out there uh on
this thing okay
so uh one other one unusual thing in
this class of device is that it actually
supports modern usb audio uh so you just
plug in a usb cable into it and it
becomes a dac which is great because i
can test it much easier that way the dac
portion of it then try to spin different
uh test cds in there and on that note
only a couple of uh
sacd tests test disks became available
when
you know these things were hot one
prototype one from sony and then another
one by philips
not much else past that those are next
impossible to find and i don't have one
uh i suppose i could go really search
for one if i was testing these players
all the time but i don't and uh when i
looked last week there was just nobody
selling
anything like that
there are some other test clips on other
samplers and i don't trust any of those
usually they're poorly generated so
anyway out of necessity i'm testing this
using the usb and then my audio
precision analyzer is able to control it
nicely and we can run a full suite of
tests at the end i'll show you some cd
and sacd tests but they're much more
limited
compared to what i can do over usb
so as always we start with our dashboard
here and
what the dashboard is that i digitally
feed the uh deck of one kilohertz
perfect one kilohertz uh
tone in 24 bit uh and 44.1 kilohertz
sampling rate and then we watch what
comes out of it everything outside of
this one spike is noise and distortion
and unfortunately we see a fair bit of
distortion in here this spike is going
up to about -108 or so
and
in this day and age it's just not that
great um i have hundred dollar dax that
way outperformed this but anyway this is
on the rca output
we get slightly better performance if we
go to balanced app with xlr output
and but we still have our distortion
although a little bit less now down to
minus 110 db
um synad is the ratio of all these noise
and distortions that you see relative to
the amplitude of of uh
this main signal that we want so it's
ratio of unwanted to wanted
expressed as a db the higher the number
the better uh in that regard and uh 105
is actually surprisingly higher than i
thought i was going to see out of a
marine's product um and uh it lands
in above average very good category i
call it there are about 360 decks that
have been tested in here and lands you
know like a slightly above average
average probably here uh
if i was testing a 99 deck and it landed
in here i would say hmm they could do
better because even 99 dax not land in
this blue area
and here we are in the next category
down and this is a 7500
device
so better than expected but not nearly
as good as it needs to be
quickly measuring a weakness in the unit
which is signal noise ratio dynamic
range and
we see that it lands around 100 304 db
that's about
17 to 18 db of dynamic range
uh most people buy these high resolution
disks expect to get a lot more
performance than a cd and unfortunately
we're not going to get it as far as the
noise performance you're limited by what
the hardware can do as opposed to what
the format can do
a lot of times people complain why are
you testing just one kilohertz you know
how does it perform with music with many
more tones well this is a simulation of
music if you will uh in that this test
tone has 32 tones in it and it's at high
sample rate of 192 kilohertz so we are
testing high resolution audio here it
does well uh almost 20 bits of
distortion free range and that means
from the tip here down to that's our
imaginary line in here that we would
draw
and i gave a credit that it's at minus
120 and -120 is about um 20 db so uh 20
bits sorry
so it's pretty good and it also doesn't
have a lot of frequency dependency a lot
of times i test products and this starts
to climb up here as frequencies get
higher but this is nice and flat so
good showing in here
on linearity linearity is just an
accuracy test that says if we keep
lowering the digital samples and then
ask the dac to produce the corresponding
voltage and we get rid of all distortion
and noise so we're just looking at the
level itself how accurate is it
and if it's perfectly accurate this line
would be at zero means there's zero
deviation and i expect to see that out
of again any deck that's above a hundred
dollars here we sort of start to
struggle a little bit early on and by
the time we get to here which is about
20 bits
uh we start to uh you know go above my
half a db threshold that i'd like to see
so not good um
it's certainly not good for 7500
but not embarrassingly bad either there
are
you know dacs that go up like this
but again this day and age performance
is so optimized in standalone decks that
i'd like to see flat line in here not
this kind of accuracy error
uh most disappointing is this jitter
test
and and uh
basically this test what you want to see
is this tone over here and these little
ticks over here
excuse me everything else is unwanted in
here and when they're symmetrical
around this main tone they're jitter
components that every every frequency of
jitter if a sinusoidal generates
one plus one minus distortion spike
and uh
usually the levels are the same so i'm
not sure if these are exactly jitter
components or not but they they're
definitely interference patterns or and
unwanted if you will and they're so
pronounced to be at very specific
frequencies
that a designer should be able to run a
test like this and say hmm this is
happening at plus or minus two kilohertz
so that means there's a source of two
kilohertz interference
in the dac in the unit
where do i have a two killer stone a
hans in this circuit that does two
kilohertz let me try to shield that let
me try to filter that let me try to
improve the power supply design
a lot of times also this kind of thing
is input dependent in this case it is
not because i'm running both coax input
digital speed of input and usb both of
them show identical problem that means
that the the problem is endemic to the
player design itself
these spikes are generated internally to
the unit and it's just pure interference
patterns there's also very low frequency
interference patterns jitter around the
main tone whenever you see this widening
we call that a skirt
and
that's very low frequency jitter so the
plus and minus that it generates are
hugging the 12 kilos tone
on this good news is that it's not
audible these things are at threshold of
hearing and that's with a full amplitude
12 killers which you don't get in music
so i don't don't think
you're gonna hear jitter but you know
from engineering design hygiene which i
expect in this class a product i expect
these problems to not be there uh this
unit by the way weighs 40 pounds i think
it's exceptionally heavy so somebody
went overboard and added 35 pounds worth
of weight to this unit to be over
designed and over you know good
uh overly good and i expect the same
thing in the electronic design and it's
not there
um
the noise problem comes back to haunted
in this test which is intermodulation
test
60 hertz and seven killers two tones at
the same time and we're changing the
amplitude from low to high and
that allows us to measure interference
patterns between those two but
importantly
we're simultaneously measuring low
frequency performance of device and high
frequency at the same time whereas with
one kilohertz we're sort of middle of
the road this thing has got treble and
bass at the same time being measured
when this graph is sloping down it means
that it's noise dominated it's not
distortion that we worry about and so
from here to here is basically dominated
by how noisy the unit is
i have two reference points
on top is a nine dollar headphone dongle
from razer
nothing special about it other than this
is a 9 to 10 bucks throwaway
product and down here is an older
dac and headphone amp from topping
called the x3 pro
and this is two or three year old
technology and is way outperforming this
moran's unit satan unit it's got so much
lower noise it's about i don't know 10
or 15 db lower noise which is hugely
significant
and uh
you know when we get down here and
the graph starts to turn up that means
that noise is low enough that allows
distortion to be seen and the two match
each other over here and that is what i
show in the dashboard so the dashboard
is the best case situation
for this product but in reality if you
look at it as the music is quieter than
maximum it's just doesn't have
competitive signal-to-noise ratio not
broken i've seen high index that are
worse than this non-colored dongle but
you know not very good
when i got the unit and i suspect that's
the default it has two filters only uh
modern dax let you select you know one
of six or seven or eight not that that's
great necessarily
um and but this has only two
and the default one that was turned on
is this filter one which i know morans
likes because even in their av receivers
this is what they ship with and this
filter is extremely slow what we want to
do from theory point of view when i'm
playing 44.1 kilo sampling nothing above
this line should be visible that means
the line should come here flat and then
go down to zero that's an ideal of
course we're not going to get the idea
and uh but we want something close to it
and this slow one that just goes on
forever it's just not good as you'll see
in a second
but luckily it has another filter the
filter number two if you set that
it it rolls it up but it still takes its
time to to come down and never comes
down a ton only 80 db
on this thing
notice that if you use a slow filter you
actually get a roll-off that starts
around 10 or 12 kilohertz so it actually
takes away some of the highs as it plays
so it you can't have the effect of
having a softer highs if your hearing is
excellent uh most of us older folks are
not going to hear the difference but if
you're younger and your hearing extends
all the way up to 17 18 19 killers uh
you're to hear 2 or 3 db droop in high
frequencies so if your system was bright
and you don't like bright sounds
the slow filter
will give you that response it's not the
way to correct your speaker you should
go and
you know use equalization to correct it
because this has other problems when you
don't
do what the theory says which is chunk
turn everything off you get this kind of
response so
the red is is with the
filter number two this is the response
you get and that this is a 99.3 year old
dac you can see how much higher the
noise and distortion is
because we didn't filter enough of that
ultrasonic and at any rate the dac is
not all that great
um
if i change the sampling rate to 192 or
i use one of the other filters we can
get better performance down to here
but we're still way short of what a 99
dollar card is doing so we've got a
bunch of ultrasonic noise and hash and
other problems all into man mingling
because this measurement goes up to 90
kilos uh bandwidth so goes way above
audible band as it should in this case
because you've got a high res player
you're expected to perform well above
audible or frequency sorry i got a hair
on my nose
so anyway moving right along
i don't have a test cd as i mentioned
for sacd uh
um
and so but i do have music uh uh that i
try to play in it um
first upon that i try to uh
play was uh antonin's uh vorjax uh
concert that i have in here and oddly
even though it's an sacd uh you can see
the symbol down here i put that in there
and it just said no disk it did not try
to read it and wouldn't play it at all
very strange uh maybe this is
multi-channel
uh i wonder if that's the problem i
don't know
but uh
i have this uh another concert uh
classic that i played in there and and
this is the spectrum that you see in
here so i just played the first track of
every strike i played and we see this
spectrum over here um
if you look in here
we have what is expected to be in music
which is the low frequencies are always
the loudest and as the frequencies go
higher and higher and higher the level
drops you know more and more and more uh
a natural music recording would just
continue with this slope going down to
nothing
in this case that's not what's happening
it goes down here and then all of a
sudden it goes up in what looks
to have a very specific pattern of noise
this is the classic dst 64 or 1x dsd
which is what they say cd is
noise shaping
they have this one bit encoding that
generates horrendous amount of
noise in here and using a feedback loop
they're able to take that noise and push
it up into a higher frequency
essentially modulates it up to a higher
frequency and spits it out out of the
output of the deck there's some kind of
filter in there that is causing these
notches so there's some attempt inside
this player to filter some of that but
usually they don't want to filter down
to 20 kilohertz because then they can't
say it's a high risk player and so what
happens is that you pump out all this
noise into your system and this is again
analog output coming out of the player
as is playing a real sacd this is not
examining some digital bits this is an
actual waveform coming out and the
amplitude of this noise at hotter
killers is the same as music at two or
three kilohertz so this is quite high
yes we get this kind of noise in other
dac's and some power amplifiers and so
forth but they're rarely
this high where they're competing with
your music so
you know what does that do i don't know
the amplifier will probably take out the
killers and try to amplify it uh you
better hope that that amp was tested up
to 100 kilohertz and it doesn't
oscillate um because if it oscillates it
could do crazy things and
you could also get into modulation this
distortion your speaker probably won't
play any of this but who knows what your
twitter does your twitter may have
resonances at 20 30 kilohertz they get
activated by this so instead of having a
level this low they may be up here and
they may also intermodulate down in
audible rant now these are very rare
things
but the point being is that there's
nothing good in here uh you know i
wanted a high-res music i wanted to go
this is cd basically i wanted to go past
whatever was in here and capture that
and instead of capturing that the format
spits out all this noise and stores it
in there permanently in the file and the
player happily plays most of it so uh
this came up in the last video i did on
octave music people said well you just
examined the file um you know that
that's all filtered out in a player well
you can see a real player over here an
iron one definitely not filtering it is
spitting it out faithfully so not good
i didn't think anybody who cared about
cd playback on a transport like this but
people on the thread argued and wanted
to see cd testing so i ran a couple of
tests
when i'm playing cd and testing it i can
only run static tests i can't do the
sweeps like the imd that you saw because
my analyzer can't control what the
player is doing but i do have just a
standard one kilohertz tone and i play
that and i got this you know distortion
spray
but the cyanide's around 91 db best case
ideal there's 90 60 be 97 db and if you
allow for dithering and other things 91
dbs is almost as good as it gets for uh
um playing back 16 bit content as far as
cyanide maybe you can get up to 93 or 94
db so there's a two three
four than
what it should do
on this so it's basically giving you a
15 db of of uh
performance instead of 16 db
but it's not something i would lose
sleep over and there was some discussion
about how is the decoding done on uh on
this player and whether it converts
everything to dsc or not uh so i ran the
same test but took a wide band spectrum
and there is some noise out here
um
but i'm not sure
what that tells us uh this notch in here
is kind of strange um so i don't know
what it's doing by the way these spikes
are aliasing uh
i shouldn't say
imaging problems because the filters are
not very good
this is what happens when you don't
filter things you get this thing and you
get a shadow of it at sampling rate
minus the uh frequency that you were
testing so
but anyway
cd rate is fine but
i don't know why you want to play cd
this day and age on transport i know
some people do it
i would personally just rip it and
be done with it
anyway so where are we a lot of times
i'm fearful that somebody buys these
things and spend all this money and they
get incredibly poor performance which is
very common in high-end audio that's not
the case in here moran's clearly has
done some homework in here to make sure
that this is this performance is
competent and it's not embarrassingly
bad it wasn't just designed by you know
ear and pride that it would sound good
um
it was done with some care uh enough
care no uh you know just i shouldn't be
able to buy a 99 deck and way out
performance 7 500 unit but uh seeing how
this is basically gets close enough to
transparency if you have it and you like
playing as a cd physically um you know
by all means this is one option for you
um on this uh are there cheap units that
work just as well i don't know and it's
hard to test them if they don't have usb
input so
you know it's it's not up to me at this
point to recommend or not recommend this
device if you're for a member you can go
and and vote on my unreviewed products
and you can see that most people i think
i'm voting it
well yeah more or less correctly they're
saying it's not terrible it's the half
of the people and a quarter say is fine
and quarter say is bad and then if a
couple people think it's great um but if
you want to impact these things join
audio size review and you o2 get to vote
how good a product is whether it should
be recommended or not and not just me on
this thing
okay
um don't have anything else for you i'm
hoping to keep up with the text reviews
but in general there are probably 10 to
20 30 reviews in writing that i do
versus what you see in videos so if you
want to see more of these i suggest
staying current with with the website
okay see you in a future video bye